nouveau rebondissement aujourd'hui dans
la bien sombre affaire du meurtre du
petit grégory
le principal témoin à charge contre
bernard laroche inculpé avant-hier est
revenu sur ses déclarations devant les
journalistes
isabelle bechler 15 ans principal témoin
à charge de bernard laroche a craqué
elle se retrouve ce matin après un
week-end en famille pour finalement
innocentées sont doucement fleuriel de
bien tu as le pivot de lampaul un pivot
auprès d'un fragile jamais été sur et
sur les ponts repoussa ou mois s'était
noyée j'ai jamais utile
tu connais pas les poches ou des seuls
bon jeu bernard innocent du gouffre et
les ne semble jamais tech mon confrère
personnellement j'attendais ces
rétractations 1 ne me surprennent donc
pas du tout et elle l'aimé meuf pas
davantage mais ça fragilise quand même
considérablement le le dossier
non parce qu'il y à d'autres éléments un
côté qui permettent de tenir peu de cas
de ce ces rétractations ses autres
éléments particuliers des témoignages de
camarades de lycée
elles seront peut-être la lumière